everybody knows how and recently
separated father of three country star
Jimmy Allen has found himself in the
center of a disturbing extramarital
Scandal that could end his career with
accusations of rape
according to variety a lawsuit was filed
by a former employee a woman in her 20s
alleging Alan quote raped her and
repeatedly subjected her to sexual abuse
and harassment over a period of 18
months which at one point left her
hospitalized your inspiration one of the
alleged attacks occurred in March of
2021 while in La filming an episode of
American Idol quote after the idol
taping she woke up naked in her hotel
room in severe pain and bleeding having
remembered nothing of what happened the
night before she says Alan was laying
next to her in bed she had lost her
virginity through no choice of her own
Allen denies the accusations but admits
he had a consensual nearly two-year
sexual relationship with this Jane Doe
and quote only after things ended
between us to she hire a lawyer to reach
out and ask for money
Allen and his pregnant wife of nearly
three years announced their separation
April 21st they both filed for divorce
April 28th citing irreconcilable
differences
[Music]